hallo mein name ist supernett sich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video in letzter zeit spielt jeder
youtuber das spiel hallauer game
das sieht so aus also wir haben hier
zwei verschiedene sachen vorgeschlagen
hier beispielsweise einmal den jaguar e
type und den hipster fragt mich nicht
wieso diese beiden begriffe dort
stehende dort hat jaguar e-type hess
6500 richmond research ist das heißt so
oft wird er im monat im internet gesucht
man muss halt jetzt gegeneinander
abwägen ob hier wird ein hipster
monatlich mehr gesucht oder weniger
gesucht und wenn man halt richtig liegt
da bekommt man dann punkte wenn man
falsch liegt dann verkackt man dafür
packen an sich allerdings nicht so
witzig ist habe ich gedacht wenn ich
falsch liege klatsche ich mir eine
allerdings nicht so doll weil ich hab
zahnschmerzen und wenn eine pussy und
wir fangen jetzt an der jaguar e-type
wird also monatlich 60.000 besucher
tipps damit monatlich öfter gesucht eine
million dgg zu lesen gibt es da eine
million und everett hat auf jeden fall
mehr als einem ich habe gar nicht
getroffen hat wehgetan
news corp csx corp bridgepoint to der
durchschnittsmensch schafft nur drei
einer einer der drei aneinander richtig
zu erraten
das knacken wir doch saves man bei dem
spiel gibt's halt nix irgendwie von
wegen ja ich muss mich ein spielen oder
so weil wie will man sich da ein spielen
hier ist die ganze zum bluttest bis hd
sind 1,8 millionen euro baut ihf hat ich
würde sagen weniger weil das hat ja
nicht mal ein bild da drin
oh ja okay es hat nur 50.000 all about
eve hat nur 50.000 und es kann man super
safe mehr also kann man sogar 1,5
millionen durchschnittlich joel hat auf
jeden fall auch mehr als 1,2 wird die
dann so wenig gesucht
die jubeln mir zu dort das ist das ist
cool man das ist richtig nett von euch
wieso wird bei mir das rechte bild am
anfang nie angezeigt ich meinen princess
thaliana da findet man doch was die wird
auf jeden fall öfter gesucht als uganda
da bin ich mir relativ sicher genau 100
22.000 mehr china wird auch mehr gesucht
als princess da nämlich 1,8 millionen
chelsea ist halt einerseits in londoner
stadtviertel andererseits halt auch der
demnach benannte fußballclub ich würde
sagen weniger 84 millionen
ich dachte gerade so chelsea wird
wahrscheinlich schon echt oft gesucht
aber china muss doch wohl eher gesucht
werden als ein stadtteil von london und
einfachere cases auch noch ein sehr
bekannter name das stimmt natürlich isla
mit einer million gegen formel 1 alter
das ist richtig eng aber ich würde sagen
f1 wird weniger oft gesucht 4 millionen
ich habe mich von vergessen zu klatschen
[Musik]
marke mix wird definitiv öfter gesucht
als ray charles das stimmt mal comics
king day
ich glaube ja ich glaube vor allem nach
seinem tod wird er sehr oft gesuchte an
glas es werden definitiv
ich hätte nicht gedacht das ist so
schwer es mehr als drei zu schaffen
buddhismus gegen six nations ich glaub
six nations hat weniger also ja okay das
war richtig buddhismus hat auf jeden
fall mehr moses hat auf jeden fall mehr
als sechster so viel mehr hat ja gar
nicht hass of glory ich würde sagen es
hat circa genau so viel ich sage aber
mal ein bisschen mehr 22.000
paul rental gegen mauth nix ich weiß
nicht mehr wie viermal comics hatte aber
ich glaube es war wenig es war einfach
genau gleich viel microsoft word hat
glaube ich weniger als marke mix eine
million millionen
ich denke suchen partikeln den späteren
crafter wurde 400.000 mal gesucht und
luca 180 millionen mal
also insgesamt ich weiß jetzt nicht wie
oft monatlich erstmal muss ich mich noch
klatschen für vorhin also mein gott es
hat es hat meine ganze rechte sieht man
dass die total angeschwollen ist das ist
jetzt die letzte runde die wir machen
meine damen und herren ich versuche
jetzt irgendwie mehr zu schaffen ufo mit
820.000 gegen franz beckenbauer ich
würde sagen franz beckenbauer hat
weniger weil ufo wird hier schon okay
90.000 hat der brand an polizisten hat
das hatten wir doch schon ich würde
sagen die hat mehr als franz beckenbauer
genau 370.000 totaler palace weiß ich
nicht ich sag mal weniger 14.000 sogar
nur okay das war gut ross setford
definitiv mehr als 14.000 ach guck doch
mal ein bild hier super universal
pictures gegen groß reken ich bin mir
nicht sicher aber ich würde sagen
weniger okay das hätte ich gar nicht mal
gedacht ich denke die ganze zeit in
insgesamten searches und nicht nur
monatlich deswegen denke ich glaube ich
die ganze zeit irgendwie falsch nehmer
hat auf jeden fall mehr als universe der
hat nämlich vier millionen monatliche
rate ist hat definitiv weniger der hat
nur 4000 der nächste dem wir haben dass
kelly clarkson der hat die die die hat
wenig wie gibt kann ich auch noch mal
vernünftig reden ist jetzt ein sehr
aktuelles thema ich würde aber sagen
trotzdem weniger ok 60.000 dann haben
wir als nächstes das ding das ist ein
sänger der wird auf jeden fall mehr
gesucht als die refugee crisis donnie
darko definitiv weniger hcg scott dixon
bissen in die top ten of players are my
gosh an dieser stelle würde ich auch das
video beende meine damen
wenn ihr sowas nochmal wollt unbedingt
daumen hoch gehen und schreibt man die
kommentare was ihr als letztes gegoogelt
hab' ich glaube bei mir war es pizza
lieferant